good afternoon so today we are going to
talk about this unusual family of
viruses that undergo reverse
transcription so we're going to talk
about the process by which reverse
transcriptions occur and integration of
the DNA into the genome and this began
at the very beginning of the 20th
century with two observations one in
1908 by that to investigators the
discovery of a virus that caused
leukemia and chickens remember 1908 not
long after viruses were first discovered
based they found a virus a filterable
agent which could cause leukemia in
chickens and then a couple years later
also in chickens the discovery of a
virus that causes sarcomas a certain
another type of tumor a solid tumor as
opposed to a leukemia a malignancy of
blood cells and that was done by peyton
rous and we'll visit him again in a few
weeks to talk about the implications of
that discovery eventually these two
viruses were called tumor viruses
because they cause tumors and at some
point they were found to contain an RNA
genome so tumor viruses RNA genomes came
many years later because if you remember
we didn't even know what the genetic
material was at least for DNA until the
40s and then RNA until the 1950s so
these tumor viruses had RNA genomes and
the puzzling question was how could they
transform cells such transformation as
we'll see later on is the process by
which you transform a cell so it becomes
immortal and has other properties as
well we'll talk about that in more
detail so these viruses could transform
cells by causing tumors leukemias or
sarcomas they could transform cells so
how could that do that finally in 1970
the enzyme within these particles was
discovered that carries out this reverse
transcription that was done by two
different investigators Howard
David Baltimore and five years later
they get they got the Nobel Prize for
that work so let's look a little bit at
this in detail reverse transcriptase was
an enzyme discovered in these tumor
viruses these are any tumor viruses
because there are also DNA tumor viruses
which we're not talking about today an
enzyme that seemed to counter the
central dogma which by the 70s was well
established that you have DNA is the
genetic material that makes RNA which
makes protein this is the flow of
genetic information suddenly these
viruses come along they have an enzyme
in the virus particle that can take RNA
and make DNA out of it so this was
believed to be contrary to the old dogma
so they were called retroviruses because
they can reverse the flow of genetic
information instead of DNA to RNA at
went from RNA to DNA so that's where the
name for this family comes from the
retro verdi or the retroviruses and
here's where they are on our Baltimore
scheme so now you know that this scheme
which was put together by David
Baltimore he was also the investigator
who one of the code discovers of the
reverse transcriptase who got the Nobel
Prize in 1975 remember there are seven
genome types and here are the
retroviruses their genome is positive
strand RNA but this goes through a DNA
intermediate to get to mRNA and we'll
talk about how that works today now
Howard teman had been working on these
RNA tumor viruses for many years and
what he found was when you infected
cells with them the cells were
permanently changed and so he his
hypothesis was that somehow these
viruses became a permanent resident in
the cell's genome and his theory arose
that the somehow the viral RNA is copied
into DNA which then gets integrated into
the host cell chromosome and he called
that the provirus this is called the
provirus hypothesis the idea that the
retroviruses these already tumor viruses
made DNA which integrated into the cell
so for many years it was a theory
because no one could find an enzyme that
could do this and in fact howard taman
tried for many years
he couldn't find an enzyme that would
take the viral RNA and copy it into DNA
but this is a necessary step of course
if you want this virus genetic
information to become a permanent part
of the host cell you have to have an
enzyme that convert it can convert it
from RNA to DNA would cells have such an
enzyme do you think could they copy that
viral RNA into DNA now based on what
I've told you you should say no but you
will see that in fact there are reverse
transcriptase in cells we'll talk about
those later but I haven't told you that
yet so the answer so far is no viruses
can't do that you need is some other
kind of end cells can't do it you need a
viral enzyme so here are the two papers
or parts of the two papers from
Baltimore and teman now you may remember
Baltimore was working on RNA polymerases
of viral rnas he worked on the polymer
aces of plus strand viruses remember in
the RNA synthesis lecture we talked
about experiments where he infected
cells and he made extracts at different
times after infection and showed that
you could incorporate triphosphates into
large RNA so given that he then looked
at the minus strand viruses and he found
in the particle in RNA polymerase which
is exactly as you would predict because
those are negative stranded RNAs that
can't be translated so he was working
for many years on polymer aces of RNA
viruses and Howard kemon had this
provirus hypothesis for many years but
he wasn't an entomologist and here this
young guy David Baltimore came along he
had just gotten his PhD at the
Rockefeller University was in his 30s he
did a couple of experiments in bumi
showed reverse transcriptase in these
particles but Howard got the message
shortly before that so they'll both
ended up doing the same experiment so we
have these back-to-back papers in nature
rna-dependent RNA polymerase and virions
of these tumor viruses so for the
hundredth episode of my podcast last
fall I interviewed David Baltimore so I
strongly suggest you listen to that it's
really interesting we asked him to sort
of reminisce about these early
days and what he was thinking about it's
now 70 or 75 years old so it's very
interesting history and also we did one
on reverse transcription which has video
associated with it so depends how you
like to learn if you like to learn with
someone standing in front of you with
talking it's fine but in this episode on
reverse transcription we made it a
conversation three people sitting around
a room and talking about reverse
transcription which is what i am doing
today except i don't have two other
people talking with me so this works
very well this is one of the most
popular episode so i suggest you check
those out now the idea that an RNA virus
would make a DNA copy of its genome and
then put that into the cell didn't come
out of nowhere there was precedent for
that and the president came from
bacteriophages and in particular lambda
bacteriophage which is a virus of
bacteria with a double-stranded DNA
genome was known to be able to integrate
its DNA into the bacterial chromosome so
this original idea that this phage could
do this came from genetic studies where
genes were mapped on the virus itself
the phage lambda and the viral genes as
these were integrated into chromosomal
DNA of the bacteria and the order was
different so here on the top is the DNA
of the phage as its integrated into the
bacteria they didn't actually know was
integrated all they knew is that these
bacteria had a stable property of a
phage in their genome and you could get
it to come out now and then so the maps
of the viral genes were NR a and J but
when you took the phage itself and map
the genes in the phage you came out with
a different order and people didn't
really understand what this meant until
alan campbell in 1962 said aha if you
circularize the phage DNA and then
integrate it into the bacterial
chromosome then you'll change the gene
order and you get this order which we
see from genetic studies so he said this
is what happens the phage DNA becomes
circular and it goes into the bacterial
genome and and there's a specific site
on the phage where that
pens all the time and so eventually this
was proven to be true so this was in
their literature by the mid 60s so Taman
in baltimore we're really building on
this and saying that these tumor viruses
do the same thing so this is what a RNA
tumor virus looks like on the left is an
electron micrograph and they are
envelope viruses you can see the
envelope on the outside this envelope of
courses is full of spikes although you
can't see them very well and in the
middle is a very dark Center and
immediately that was called the core
although more more accurately we would
call it a capsid or a new clio capsid
because it's inside an envelope right so
here on the right is a diagram the
envelope is on the outside studded with
the glycoproteins then understand within
that of course is the core or the capsid
or the nucleocapsid and that is actually
composed of a viral protein and within
that is the viral RNA genome which is
shown in green here and there these are
plus stranded RNAs but there are two
molecules per virion not just one as we
see with most other RNA viruses there
are two now also there's something very
unusual here up to this point in this
course if I told you this was a plus
strand RNA virus and I said does
anything have to come into the cell with
that plus strand you would say no it's a
plus strand it can be translated and you
would be right up until this point but
from this day onwards this is the
exception to that rule the retroviruses
they do bring in some viral proteins
with them even though they are plus
stranded because that plus strand is not
translated when it gets into the cell as
you will see so among the proteins that
are brought in or the reverse
transcriptase RT there's another protein
called the integrase I n which we will
talk about and then the a protease PR
which is involved in chopping up the
poly protein and this is a map of this
genome because again it's one of these
problems so if you have a plus strand
RNA how do you get a bunch of viral
proteins from one
RNA and this illustrates that so at the
top is a map of the genome and it goes
from left to right there is a region
encoding the core or the capsid proteins
it's called the gag protein then in the
middle of the enzymes the reverse
transcriptase and the integrase and one
other enzyme that we'll talk about
that's called the pawl gene and then at
the right of the genes encoding the
envelope those are the glycoproteins
that are in the envelope with the virus
now note on either end of this genome
this is actually a DNA copy of the retro
viral genome that's being shown here
there are two repeated sequences called
ltrs or long terminal repeats we will
visit those in a moment when we talk
about reverse transcription now in the
cell as you will see this DNA copy of
the viral RNA is integrated into the
chromosome of the host cell and the
chromis the host cell makes mrnas from
that DNA copy all right so last time we
heard about transcription dna-based RNA
synthesis taking DNA making mRNA from it
so this is what happens to make retro
viral rnas the host cell does that the
virus doesn't do it because this is just
like a cellular gene now it's a
double-stranded DNA copy inserted in the
genome so here's the mRNA or one mRNA
that is made it's a nearly full length
copy of the genome but it is not a
full-length copy it's missing sequences
at either end and we'll get that to that
in a moment this can be directly
translated to produce a gag paul protein
which is then processed to make a bunch
of little proteins by viral protease
which is this yellow guy right here but
the translation stops here it doesn't go
into envelope for this particular kind
of retrovirus so how do you get at that
information well the retroviruses do it
by splicing this mRNA they remove some
of the sequences and in the middle here
and now you have an mRNA which can be
translated to produce these envelope
proteins so you take one RNA you either
translate it directly or you splice if
the splicing removes out the gag Paul
and now you can access downstream
so here's the general scheme of
infection the retrovirus binds a cell
receptor it enters the cell it gets
uncoded and the the RNA genomes there
are two of them get copied into DNA
double-stranded DNA that makes its way
into the nucleus and then it integrates
into the host cell DNA the integrated
form is called the proviral DNA that's
by definition what that is okay so we're
going to look at this step in a moment
the proviral DNA is copied by cellular
DNA dependent RNA polymerase to make
mRNA and these mrnas go out into the
cytoplasm by the normal cellular
pathways they can be translated to make
glycoproteins the envelope glycoproteins
which go to the plasma membrane they can
be translated to form the capsid
proteins the gag proteins and the
polymerase or they can go into new
virions so all the same messenger RNA
with the exception of that one that's
spliced if these were all this one is a
spliced mRNA because it encodes the
envelope proteins but these two are full
length and this one goes into virions so
the genome of a retrovirus is nothing
more than an mRNA that is made by
transcription of a integrated copy of
the proviral DNA the new viruses are
then made by budding which we will talk
about later on now reverse transcriptase
is an enzyme that copies RNA to make DNA
all the same rules apply for as for
other enzymes that we've talked about
the template is copied in a three to
five prime direction the this newly
synthesized nucleic acid is made in a 5
to 3 prime direction by stepwise edition
of triphosphates to the 3 prime end and
reverse transcriptase is require a
primer they are a primary dependent
enzyme the primer can be RNA or DNA
doesn't matter the primer must have a
paired three prime terminus of this base
here of the primer the last base has to
be base paired it can't be floating away
some enzymes don't mind if the three
prime end is not base paired but this
one does
the template can be RNA which is the
viral RNA or it can be DNA you'll see
why that is important and deoxy ntps are
incorporated not RNA it does not make
RNA this ends it makes just DNA the
template can be DNA or RNA but it only
makes DNA and of course just like every
other polymerase the incoming the right
one the incoming the oxy ntp you
selected by base pairing here so that's
reverse transcriptase now reverse
transcriptase has associated with it a
second activity which is a separate
domain in the protein it's an enzyme
called RNA ch so this is a enzyme that
degrades RNA as you can gather from the
name but it has a very specific activity
first of all it will cleave RNA it's an
RNA state it's an RN ace but it only
does so when the substrate is double
stranded or in duplex form that duplex
can be RNA RNA it can be double-stranded
RNA or it can be RNA DNA either one
doesn't matter the RNAs will cut the RNA
strand it's an endonuclease which means
it cuts internally it doesn't chop the
ends off which would be an exonuclease
so enzymes that take off one base at the
time from the ends those are EXO's this
is an endonucleases it cleaves
internally and it makes short pieces of
RNA oligonucleotides with a five prime
phosphate and a 3 prime hydroxyl so here
is a duplex molecule could be DNA RNA or
RNA RNA RNA SH is cleaving where these
red arrows are shown it's cleaving
between this oxygen and the phosphate
all the time so it's cleaving five prime
to the phosphate and it gives it Cleaves
every ten bases or so so give short
pieces and they all have a five prime
phosphate in the three prime of age
could be different depending on the
specificity you could have a five-prime
low wage for example but it doesn't it
happens to cleave just like that okay so
that's reverse transcriptase an RNA say
to we'll revisit those in the life cycle
in a moment but let's start with the
noam of these viruses this is what it
looks like in the virion the two RNAs
there plus stranded and they are shown
here in terms of what's encoded that
gives the five prime and these are
capped rnase because there are messages
they're produced by paul two of the host
cell and then they encode the gag the
Paul in the envelope and they also have
a poly a sequence after three prime end
in the virion they are base paired with
a tRNA a transfer RNA this of course you
all know is a molecule needed for
translation of mRNAs it brings the
individual amino acids to the mRNA the
virus puts two into its capsid base
paired at a very specific place on the
RNA shown here and you'll see why those
are there in addition this whole complex
this RNA and the tRNAs is coated with a
protein called the nucleocapsid protein
that's also very unusual for a plus
strand RNA virus usually they come into
the cell without any associated proteins
this one has reverse transcriptase and
integrates but it also has NC protein
along its whole length and that's
because the first step when this virus
gets into a cell is that it has to be
reversed transcribed so there are two
RNAs to tRNAs the RNA is coated with
nucleocapsid protein NC and there are
about 50 to 100 molecules of reverse
transcriptase / virion but you don't
need to know that but you may be
interested as their one or are there
many so there you go there 50 to 100 to
anyone ever asks you in 50 years how
many molecules of RNA and RT in a very
on there you go now the two strands of
RNA in the very and why are there two
what we think is because these viruses
make a lot of mistakes in their
replication so if you have two copies
you have a better chance of
reconstructing a fully infectious virus
than if you have just one so they have
two copies of every gene not just one so
they're highly resistant to mutation or
to UV or ionizing radiation which of
course is a
problem for many viruses so if one
strand has a uv-induced mutation it can
be soup that part of this day RNA can be
supplied by the other part of the strand
so this implies that during reverse
transcription there's a lot of jumping
back and forth and that eventually you
get a molecule that will work okay so
this is the idea is that that makes them
more resistant to mutation let's take a
look at the tRNA which is bound to a
very specific place now we're looking at
the very left hand part of the RNA here
the rest is off to the right we're not
looking at it here's our tRNA so this is
the cap at the five prime end and this
tRNA is base paired it is hybridized to
a very specific sequence in the viral
RNA equal de Bruyne primer binding site
PBS and that's shown right here and this
is going to be a primer for reverse
transcription that's the function of
this molecule this tRNA molecule now its
base paired here in a very interesting
way it depends on the virus the
particular way that this tRNA is base
paired but below is the situation with a
particular kind of RNA tumor virus the
avian sarcos asst and leukemia virus
Group A SLV there many different kinds
of RNA tumor viruses here is the part of
the genome that is normally present here
this is the primer binding site right
there and you can see it's extensively
base paired forms a very nice stem loop
with a bulge here's the tRNA and this
virus takes two in particular a tRNA
which would normally be conjugated to
the amino acid tryptophan and every
retrovirus has its particular tRNA that
it likes to take in this actually base
pairs into this primer binding site like
this so here's the tRNA and you can see
this is the region of base pairing so it
melts out this region a bit fits in here
very nicely its base pairing here and
along this part of the loop and here's
the three prime end of the tRNA so
that's going to be where priming by
reverse transcriptase begins and all
this is at the very five prime end of
the
viral RNA okay so that is the primer
sign let's take a look at how this works
so here are a series of slides
illustrating how this really interesting
process of reverse transcription begins
so now we have our viral RNA which I've
rearranged in a circular way to
illustrate this process better here's
the 5 prime end here's the 3 prime end
with the poly a tail and here is our
tRNA bound to the RNA remember this
comes into the cell with reverse
transcriptase in the virion and what the
reverse transcriptase immediately does
upon getting into the cytoplasm the
virus gets uncoated a bit it still
remains in some kind of sub viral
particle but it's in the cytoplasm the
reverse transcriptase copies the five
prime end of the genome it's not much
left there it's one or two hundred basis
so it goes to the end and stops and this
is negative strand DNA so it's blue and
it's light blue it's our color coding
for various nucleic acids and as the
reverse transcriptase makes that
complementary strand the RNA SH activity
of the RT of the reverse transcriptase
chops up the RNA template so what we're
left with is a little bit of overhanging
DNA here this is called minus strong
stop DNA for historical reasons and this
template is gone that it was made from
okay and now it's going to start priming
on the other strand because it turns out
that this is complementary to some
sequences right down at the three prime
end of the RNA now here we go here's
that little piece of DNA that we made
the very three prime end is
complementary to the three prime end of
the viral RNA so basically what happens
is that base pairs there and the reverse
transcriptase continues to copy and this
happens in a complex and in the cell of
course its own in wrapped so you don't
have any of this big jumping it's all at
the molecular level of course but we
expand it to show you how it works so
the party continues around the viral
genome continues to make
negative strand DNA and as it does so
it's degrading the viral RNA template
eventually gets all the way around here
and at some point another bit of DNA
synthesis begins and that's here when
this RNA SH is degrading the RNA
template it leaves behind a little
primer called ppt which stands for poly
purine tract and the reverse
transcriptase will then begin to extend
that and of course that is making a plus
strand RNA it's darker blue so as this
is being completed this first negative
strand this plus strand is being
initiated okay moving on so now we have
made a full length minus strand that's
ending right here for now this is the
original primer binding site remember
where the tRNA started so it was copied
once and now it's being copied as it was
primed it was used as a primer site it's
been copied now here this plus strand
DNA continues it goes beyond the tRNA
because it is in fact complementary to
this part of the negative strand DNA
that's been that's been made and you can
see this is now base pairing and the
enzyme is going to continue making
another full length plus strand so we'll
end up with a minus and a plus strand in
other words a double-stranded DNA copy
of the viral RNA so this primer binding
site is being copied here and then it's
going to be copied again when the plus
strand is made the result is that we end
up having a duplication at both ends of
the genomes you remember in the
beginning I said look there's an LTR at
either end that's how this arises by
this repetitive copying of the ends you
need that because the RNA is not the
full-length copy of the genome so you
have to have this funny mechanism for
regenerating those ltrs and the LTR on
the left has a important promoter in it
so we need to have that in the LTR on
the right has a terminator and when
that's sitting in the genome as a
provirus you need to have both ltrs so
this funny business of going around and
copying this region twice gives you that
utr twice that long terminal repeat
twice
and finally we can finish up this plus
strand just look at the left-hand side
of this slide you don't have to worry
about the right at all so this is where
we left off on the left side we have
almost a full length minus strand the
light blue and now we're making a plus
strand remember we've jumped across the
gap we're going to fill this in here and
make a full length double strand and as
this happens you know originally this
minus strand had stopped right here at
the primer binding site eventually it
actually is extended more to cover this
region and that duplicates the LTR
because the LTR is made up of these
sequences you five are you three and ppt
sorry just you five are and you three so
you can see it's duplicated here so that
the final double-stranded DNA let's get
the whole viral genome and it's got an
LTR on the left and an LTR on the right
and here's the primer binding site which
is where the tRNA would be if this were
an RNA and here's ppt which is where
that the second strand of DNA synthesis
initiates so this very baroque method
gives you a double-stranded DNA copy of
the genome it duplicates the ends which
is important because you could need to
have the LTR at both ends okay
repeat the whole thing which one this
yeah so the enzyme just continues to
copy around here that's what's here and
eventually here it will go all the way
back to ppt which is here so here's ppt
it's not it's not been made into a plus
strand yet but it will be when this
copies all the way around yeah right so
if you just fill this in you would only
have one LTR so what has to happen here
is you have this strand displacement
this displaces the new plus strand and
copies in the template underneath it and
then you duplicate that LTR exactly so
that's how you get the LTR duplicated ok
ok so let's talk a little bit about
these proteins that do this interesting
copying these this is the mRNA of a
typical retrovirus the gag proteins are
encoded on the left 5 prime end we have
the Paul in the middle and the envelope
is on the right these are different
kinds of retroviruses the ASL vs the
murine leukemia viruses and here we have
HIV 1 and this is the Paul region which
encodes reverse transcriptase integrase
and RNA SH and the way these are made
are different for the different kinds of
viruses so for example the ASL vs they
some they sometimes make a full-length
Paul protein so it has polymerase RNA CH
integrase all as one protein and that
can work as a RT in RNA SH and sometimes
they cut off the integrase and that
gives you a few integrase protein and
that room that leaves you with reverse
transcriptase and RNA SH and that
functions perfectly well to reverse
transcribe and chop off the RNA as you
will see because these two things have
to go hand-in-hand you make a DNA copy
then you chop up the RNA template the
murine leukemia viruses process
all the time here so that you'll get
only a rtrn a sage and a separate
integrase and HIV also does the same
thing and it also makes a separate arty
integrase needs to be a separate protein
because it functions at a different part
of the lifestyle but the arty will
function alone but it won't remove the
RNA template unless it has an RNA sage
now these RNA these retro viral
polymerase is reverse transcriptase
azhar related to all the other kinds of
polymerase as we mentioned the other day
these are the four kinds of nucleic acid
polymerase RNA RNA RNA DNA and that's
the one we're talking about today
reverse transcriptase DNA DNA polymerase
and DNA RNA polymerase and they have
homologies that are shown here in green
areas and so here's the reverse
transcriptase and it has an asp asp
dinucleotide in this region old reverse
transcriptase has it's a signature just
as gly asp asp is a signature for the
plus strand RNA polymerase is in that
sea motif so they're all highly related
probably because they evolved from a
common precursor so here at the bottom
is a cartoon of reverse transcriptase
RNA SH this is a the two proteins fuse
together the reverse transcriptase is
over here the RNA seichas over here and
the reverse transcriptase again is like
all other polymerases it resembles the
right hand you have fingers palm and
thumb and that's shown in in yellow gray
and orange there is an active site here
shown by these two white circles and
there are two amino acids that are
conserved there that whose function is
to bind metals typically magnesium but
manganese will also work and those
coordinate the incoming triphosphates to
allow polymerization so that is the
active site where the new triphosphate
is added to the chain the RNA comes in
here over the fingers and into the palm
it's the green strand and then the
triphosphates are added and these are
DNT PS of
that gives you the blue strand so what
comes out of the active site is a duplex
a DNA RNA duplex it moves across the
surface here it reaches the RNA SH
active site which also has two metal
ions in the active site and then the RNA
is degraded so you get RNA in and RNA
out a DNA out the duplex exists only for
a short time on the surface of the
enzyme and at the top is a a model of
this complex derived from the crystal
structure we now know the structures of
a number of reverse transcriptase 'as
these were done because HIV RT is a
major drug target an antiviral drug
target so a lot of work was done to
study the polymerase to try and get
clues about how to make drugs to inhibit
it because cells don't have this enzyme
so it's a great target to treat is an
antiviral target so here you can see the
fingers domain in yellow here's the
active site right here the RNA comes in
the RNA isn't shown here but here's the
duplex molecule the rna-dna hybrid shown
here and eventually as it comes out it
will be degraded here's the RNA say
domain at the top retroviral reverse
transcriptase is a pretty slow process
compared to other polymerases it takes
about four hours for the genome to be
copied one genome takes four hours it's
a long time most of the viral plume
races are much faster it also makes a
lot of mistakes anywhere from one to ten
that in ten thousand to one in a million
mistakes so that is why these viruses
undergo a lot of mutation and we'll talk
about that a lot later in terms of HIV
so they're slow and they make mistakes
all right so we've now got our DNA copy
all of this has happened in the
cytoplasm we've got a double-stranded
DNA copy of the viral RNA now this is
going to go into the nucleus and
integrate into the chromosomal DNA and
how does that happen so here we have on
the top the double-stranded viral DNA
again we have the two ltrs at either end
and in between the rest of the genome
this is called unintegrated linear DNA
it will integrate at a place in the
chromosomal DNA it's called the host
target we'll talk more about what that
target might be it's it's rather random
there's no specific sequence but there
are restrictions as we'll talk about in
a moment so this DNA is going to
integrate into the target and become a
pro viral DNA that's the integrated DNA
we have host DNA on either side and we
have viral DNA there are two very
interesting things that happen here
right first when you integrate to a host
target the host target is duplicated on
either side of the proviral DNA and
you'll see why when we talk about the
mechanism so this is a short this is
we're talking about a four to six base
pair target that gets duplicated on
either side this is a hallmark of
reverse transcription and integration
secondly you lose two bases at either
end of the viral DNA you can see there's
a ATG here but there's only TG here so
that the two A's have been lost two A's
are clipped off either end again you'll
see why that happens when we go through
the mechanism and finally this is
transcribed by cellular DNA dependent
RNA polymerase to give it a messenger
RNA which can be used for proteins or
can become the viral RNA genome so this
is very unusual we have a viral genome
that is the process of being mRNA
transcription by a host cell enzyme and
the promoter for this mRNA synthesis you
remember from last time RNA initiates
mRNAs are initiated at specific promoter
sequences that is located in this LTR so
you need to have that LTR for mrna to be
made yes
correct it probably is a matter of
quantities early an infection there is
not much protein around to make virions
so that's preferentially translated into
protein and then when you start
accumulating enough viral proteins to
make capsids then then the pool of RNAs
get shifted to that right but they're
they're indistinguishable same molecule
so the mRNA initiates here and it's
terminated there's a specific terminator
remember same with mrna transcription of
host cell genes it's a terminator in the
right LTR so that's why we need both
ltrs but this RNA doesn't have both ltrs
because it initiates within the LTR and
terminates within the LTR that's again
why we have to do that baroque copying
to duplicate the LTR at either end
otherwise we lose sequence and that
wouldn't that wouldn't work all right
let's take a look at this integration in
a little detail so you understand this
duplication and loss of sequence so here
at the upper left is our double-stranded
retro viral DNA and this is integrase
this yellow protein in the background
here the two nucleotides from each end
are clipped off so today's these two
ends at the three prime end here and
here of the other side they're both
clipped off by the integrase so that's
the source of losing two bases and then
the three prime hydroxyl attacks the
target DNA here and here so this this is
the target the Unites chromosomal DNA of
the host cell it's being attacked by the
three prime hydroxyl of those two newly
generated ends along with the integrase
of course and it is ligated it is the
host DNA is nicked and then the nick
dens are joined with the viral DNA ends
so that's what you see on the third
panel here we've now joined the three
prime ends of the viral DNA
with host cell DNA okay so now this is
conceived our DNA is contiguous with the
host cell DNA the integrase then fills
in the gaps so these are gaps right here
where the host DNA is single-stranded
that's filled in and now you see it in
yellow and orange here and now it's
integrated so this explains the loss of
the two bases at the end and why we have
a duplicated sequence because each of
these two strands is copied to form a
duplex so that's why the target sequence
is duplicated so we start with a
double-stranded DNA you Nick you take
off two bases you Nick the target DNA
you like the viral DNA to the target you
fill in the gap and there you have an
integrated DNA a pro virus Yeah Yeah
right right
the integrations doing all of this right
and this is the magic protein integrase
which what I want to show you here is
that this is the the active or catalytic
domain and blue here of the integration
a also has two amino acids that bind
metals so they can carry out these
various activities it also has a DNA
binding domain so it's got a zinc
binding domain that core catalytic
domain shown in blue and a DNA binding
domain and this protein integrase forms
dimers as shown on the left and we think
the active form of the integrase is
actually a tetramer which is shown on
the right so four of those individual
molecules make an active enzyme and
that's the surface on which this nicking
and ligating and filling in activity
occurs right that we just went through
so here are one two three four monomers
of the integrase here's the catalytic
site right here on the surface this is
target DNA it's going to be nicked right
here and then the viral DNA will be
ligated to it so all those activities
occur on this catalytic surface of a
tetramer yeah
this is a good question I'm going to
talk about it a little right now it's
probably the integrase plus some other
cell proteins are involved in that so
the process we've been talking about
infection reverse transcription occurs
in the cytoplasm and this occurs in a
sub viral particle you see there's still
some viral proteins around it and
eventually when this is made
double-stranded DNA will be brought into
the nucleus by nuclear import so this is
small enough to go through a nuclear
pore and then this will integrate in
cellular DNA now there are some proteins
shown on this slide bath lap 2 HMG mrn
these are all proteins thought these are
cell proteins that are thought to be
involved in the integration steps and in
particular there there appear to be
interactions between baths and amarin
which helps which is believed to
localize this what's called a pre
integration complex to chromatin and
there also is believed to be
interactions between integrase which is
which of these dark molecules here and a
protein called ledge f which is
associated with nucleosomes that's
thought to bring the pre-integration
complex near the nucleus almond near a
chromosomal DNA this is a pretty active
area of investigation to sort this out
but there clearly are cell proteins that
are needed for this step to bring this
complex right next to where it needs to
be which is DNA of course now the
integration of retro viral DNA is seems
to be random there's no specific
sequence so in bacteria where lambda
integrates is an ad sequence very
specific place where the phage
integrates it's not the case for retro
viral DNA integration seems to be random
but it seems to occur where there are
exposed areas in chromatin so it's
typically associated with bent or
exposed areas of the chromatin which
makes sense I believe yes here is a
table showing
the preference sites of retroviral
integration this is done by sequencing
the proviral DNA in a variety of
different kinds of cells so you just
make cellular DNA is done from either
human cells or mouse cells and you just
sequence across the ends and you see
what cellular genes has the virus
integrated into and what we're looking
at here is percent integration in
different regions so let's look at human
cells first of all so we're looking at
first of all these viruses go into every
chromosome there's no chromosomal
preference and within the chromosome
here they have looked at integration
within genes that is within the coding
sequence or within transcription start
sites so if you randomly through a piece
of DNA into the chromosome you would
expect twenty-six percent of the time to
get with into a gene and eight percent
of the time to get into a transcription
start site okay that's just a numbers
calculation based on the number of genes
in the number of transcription start
sites the actual experimental data for
three different retroviruses are shown
here are a SLV murine leukemia virus and
HIV so there is a more than random
preference of these viruses for
integrating with in jeans so something
for some reason this virus likes to be
within genes Oh three do and
particularly HIV very much likes to be
integrated within genes if you look at
transcription start sites ASL via slight
increase but MLV and is certainly
preferring to integrate at transcription
start sites more than you would expect
my randomness and HIV as well so there
is some bias to wear these proviral DNA
sr integrating but as i said they go
into every chromosome as far as we know
and there's no specific sequence being
targeted there is a preference for
integration into DNA's that are either
bent or underground by being wrapped
around a nucleus l now remember if the
retrovirus goes into a gene and disrupts
it it mutates that gene
so retro viral insertion can cause
problems in a variety of ways and we'll
see about that when we talk about
transformation in oncogenesis so once
the proviral DNA is in your DNA it's
there forever can't get it out there's
no viral enzyme that will take it out
why would the virus do that it wants to
stay in there it's no way to get it out
actually people are working on
interesting enzymatic ways of excising
the provirus because people with HIV you
can never get rid of all the infected
cells and there's no way to get rid of
the provirus so you have to stay on
antivirals your entire life so if you
could excise the proviral DNA you would
be cured completely of infection so
people are working on ways to do this
but it's at least a decade off now these
are these were originally one of the
only fossils of viruses that we ever had
because if when these get integrated
into animals you can trackback the time
that viruses appeared in that kind of
animal and you can also time how long
these genomes have been in an animal
because they mutate every time the cell
divides and you can count the number of
mutations so you can say this has been
here 20 million years or 40 million
years or whatever when these DNA is
integrated into your germline DNA as
opposed to somatic cells that is called
an endogenous virus it's a very specific
term for being in the journal I'm we'll
come back to that so are our genomes
have tons of retrovirus related
sequences presumably from infections
many years ago and they've been
perpetuated in our genomes and some
people think that they're important and
maybe sources of new genes but we really
don't know the answer to that now this
is an integrating interesting situation
that the virus is now in the genome the
only way the virus can get out is to be
transcribed by host cell DNA and that's
done by Paul to so think about this
virus actually does not replicate its
genome right it doesn't have an RNA
polymerase or a DNA polymerase that will
replicate the genome it goes into your
host cell DNA
replicates as your chromosomal DNA
replicates but the mRNAs that are
produced or a product of transcription
so there's really no enzyme that
actually go viral enzyme that replicates
this genome okay so a summary of some of
this there's a promoter built into the
left-hand LTR we talked about you need
that for making mrna and that's that
directs the host transcription machinery
and then that mRNA is made the proteins
are encapsulated as we have said there's
no DNA replication and there's no RNA
replication really from this for this
virus only reverse transcription
integration and transcription that's the
strategy really the ultimate parasite I
think doesn't even have its own
polymerases so we have made a proviral
DNA the cell is making merrily making
mrnas which give rise to proteins and
eventually new viral particles which
encapsulate some of those mrna s so
that's retroviruses we will come back to
those later on in the second part of the
course where we talk about how they
cause cancer but before we end today
there are a couple of other viruses that
I want to tell you about that have
reverse transcriptase because RNA tumor
viruses although they were the first
ones to be just to be discovered to have
reverse transcriptase they are not the
only ones and the second is a totally
different family the Hypatia viruses
hepatitis b virus which of course
infects your liver and causes hepatitis
here's an electron micrograph on the
upper left typical envelope viruses here
is a schematic membrane derived from the
host cell studded with viral
glycoproteins and within the envelope is
the viral core or capsid containing
viral DNA this viral DNA is unusual
because it's remember gapped it's got a
piece of RNA on it and it has a protein
on it so it's actually a separate group
separate from double-stranded DNA
because it has all these unusual
features so partially double-stranded
the piece of RNA and a protein and today
you're going to learn how the genome got
to be that way I told you this the very
beginning this is an unusual genome but
the way it's produced will explain this
here's the life cycle of hepatitis b VAR
so these were discovered well after RNA
tumor viruses in the 1960s and 70s in
fact and then many years later were
found to encode a reverse transcriptase
these viruses infect the cell the core
is deposited in the cytoplasm it goes
into the nucleus and that DNA is
repaired you have to make it perfectly
double-stranded DNA or nothing can
happen to it once it's in the nucleus
it's transcribed to form messages by
host Paul to so now you have messenger
viral messenger RNAs produced these can
go out in the cytoplasm would be
translated and make a variety of
proteins they can make glycoproteins
which will eventually be used to make
new variants they can make structural
proteins now look what happens here you
make some structural proteins the caps
it and you start to form capsids in the
cytoplasm the mRNA which is a
full-length mRNA called the pre genome
gets encapsulated in there it is then
copied by a reverse transcriptase a
viral reverse transcriptase which is
brought in with the RNA it's actually
this pea protein here it's brought in
with the RNA and it makes a
double-stranded DNA copy and those sub
viral particles if you will can either
go back into the nucleus again get
repaired and go through another cycle or
late an infection they will bud from the
host cell to make new virions there's no
integration of this viral DNA into the
host cell so what protein do you think
is missing in these viruses compared
with the retroviruses integrase exactly
there's no integrase there's a reverse
transcriptase and an RNA sage but no
integrase so look at this it all that
uses reverse transcriptase for is to
copy this viral RNA into DNA doesn't use
it because it wants to integrate it just
wants to make a DNA copy so let's take
look at this reverse transcriptase
reaction it has some differences from
that which we just talked about which
are very interesting in contrast to the
retroviruses the primer for this reverse
transcription here's the viral RNA has
two very important structures within it
these act as primers there's no tRNA
bound to this RNA but rather the one of
these is going to serve as the
nucleating point for priming the other
is going to serve as a nucleating or a
primer point for making DNA as we will
see so on the upper left is the genome
is the whole genome here's one of those
structures I just showed you at one end
and the other is at the other end and
the ends have repeats just like the
retro viral rnas have repeats the direct
repeat one here is repeated the
initiation of reverse transcription
takes place at this first hairpin
structure which is very near the five
prime end of the RNA here's the cap very
much like retro viral reverse
transcription the primer is actually the
pea protein which is a combination of a
primer and reverse transcriptase and
this binds to this stem loop and it and
a reverse transcription is initiated so
now we're making a minus strand DNA copy
so the genome is plus strand it's an
mRNA made by host cell polymerase so
here this DNA is being made let's go
over here it goes a little bit into dr
one and then it jumps to the other end
of the molecule ok so watch so here the
RT is copying this loop it gets a little
bit into dr one and this sequence is
repeated at the three prime end of the
RNA and so the enzyme jumps up there and
begins copying there ok so now this we
move down to step three negative strand
DNA is being made so the enzymes going
around the circle the templates being
degraded as usual and eventually we copy
the entire genome we go all the way to
the cap structure at the five prime end
of the RNA right here and all the RNA is
degraded with the exception of a little
bit which is the RNA primer
which of course is going to serve as a
primer for the next strand of DNA so
here's that product we just made a
full-length negative strand of DNA copy
with an RNA primer left here that is
going to prime synthesis but it doesn't
go very far before it jumps to this dr
to region so it's the second template
exchange and then the enzyme begins
copying that eventually reaches the five
prime protein which is still there
that's the primer that was used to
initiate the very first round and that
strand simply jumps over to the three
prime end of the genome right here it
can't go any further here so it jumps
over here and eventually it makes a
full-length geno double-stranded genome
but it's not a full-length duplex
because there's a gap if you remember
and there's this protein is left on and
this RNA primer is left on so this piece
of RNA that we never chewed away is
what's left in the virion it's that
little piece of RNA that we find in the
vireo and this is the protein in that's
left on the viral DNA and then it's
never completely made double-stranded
there's a gap and the ends are not
joined together and that's all a process
of this unusual reverse transcription so
the result is a double-stranded DNA copy
which could either go into virions or go
back in the nucleus get repaired and
serve to make more mrnas but doesn't
integrate remember that does not
integrate so this is an alignment of the
reverse transcriptase of HIV here we
have the reverse transcriptase domain
and the integrate the RNA SH domain here
remember these two are right next to
each other in the active protein you
make DNA and you chop off the RNA
template here's RNA SH for the hepatitis
B virus reverse transcriptase here's the
polymerase domain and in addition this
has extra sequence at the n-terminus it
has a terminal protein which stays on
the DNA so this is the primer it's
clipped here so the rest of the enzyme
moves forward but the terminal protein
means is the primer for DNA synthesis
and that's what remains in the viral
genome so let's compare these two
schemes these is this summary of what
happens with retroviruses and a summary
of what happens with these padna viruses
in the Box the yellow part is what is
put into virus particles here so for the
retroviruses the RNA is packaged
remember to two molecules of RNA when
that gets in a Cell it's reverse
transcribed to make a double-stranded
DNA copy and that gets integrated the
integrated copy gives rise to the mRNA
which is packaged so that's the cycle of
retroviruses and a half be the RNA is
not packaged it is that funny
double-stranded gap molecule that is
packaged so this infects a cell it's
repaired the repair DNA gives rise to
messenger RNA the messenger RNA is
reverse transcribed to give back this
double its partially double-stranded DNA
so you can see there's a big difference
here in what is packaged here's the DNA
is packaged here the RNA is packaged for
the retroviruses the goal is to
integrate so that host cell polymerase
can make mRNA for the iPad no viruses
the substrate for host excuse me host
cell mRNA synthesis or mrna synthesis by
host cell polymerizes is this circular
DNA form which does not integrate it
remains as a free-standing DNA in the
nucleus what we call an episome there
are two other families of viruses with
reverse transcription one is a plant
virus a family of plant virus RNAs
cauliflower mosaic virus what do you
think it infects Coley flowers was a
disease of quality flowers and has been
known for many years and then at some
point someone found that these encode a
reverse transcriptase and this life
cycle is very much like the patna virus
life cycle what is packaged in the
virion is this double stranded DNA we
some gaps in it in pieces of RNA linked
to it very much like the hepatitis B
virus genome when it gets into a cell
It's Made closed circular so it can be
transcribed into an mRNA by the host
cell and then that gets reverse
transcribed to make more DNA so this
plant virus is very similar to the
hepatitis B virus there's another family
of viruses within the it's a it's a
genus within the retrovirus family
they're called foamy retroviruses now
why are these here why they different
look they are packaging DNA here we have
a retrovirus which is packaging DNA the
virus has double-stranded DNA it's got
two ltrs very much like the linear DNA
of RNA tumor viruses but this is DNA
that is packaged it goes into a cell it
integrates into the host cell DNA the
integrated proviral DNA gives rise to
mrnas those are produced by cellular DNA
dependent RNA polymerase and those are
then made double stranded by a reverse
transcriptase that gives you back the
linear DNA s and a linear DNA's are
packaged so it is completely different
from the other retroviruses in what is
packaged although the cycles are very
similar as well alright so we have three
basic ways to use a reverse
transcriptase in the life cycle one is
in common between cauliflower mosaic
virus that have had no viruses the
retroviruses package RNA the foamy
retroviruses package DNA but they all
use this very similar enzyme to copy RNA
into DNA so reverse transcriptase is the
proper name for it okay now let's talk a
brief bit about these sequences that are
in us these endogenous viruses and
related things they're all called retro
elements so this will refer to not only
endogenous retroviruses but other
related sequences that we have in our
genomes so a retrovirus related
sequences in cellular genome
and as I said before when the DNA is in
your germ line and it can be passed by
heredity it's called an endogenous
provirus most of the time humans in fact
all of the retro elements that we have
in us and we have a considerable amount
these are all replication defective so
we don't actually unless you have AIDS
you don't make retroviruses right so all
of you have retro elements you have a
lot of them but you're not making any
virus as far as we know there could be
someone walking around the earth right
now making virus but interestingly
different species have a different
status so mice have also lots of retro
elements but they make virus particles
doesn't make them sick the wild mice out
there have lots of retroviruses they're
producing that it doesn't make them sick
and it could be that at one time in our
evolution we also made retroviruses and
maybe we will again someday but all the
copies we have are heavily mutated so
they don't make particles half of almost
half of your genome is made up of this
stuff retro elements half of you is
viral I think that's amazing and this
has been with us for a long time
probably as long as we've been evolving
so the really interesting question which
we don't know the answer to is is it
good for us there's some there's some
evidence and other animals that some of
these retro elements are actually
beneficial and there is one species
where it is believed that placental
development actually depends on an a
retro element that is actually expressed
to form a protein there's no evidence in
people for this so these are diagrams of
some of these retro elements we up at
the top as an endogenous retrovirus so
this is a proviral DNA that is in your
germ line all right and we have between
one and a hundred copies of what are
called human endogenous retrovirus
curves and again we don't make viruses
because they're defective but someone
has cloned out these sequences and fix
them
you can make a virus from the fixed
sequence so here's a virus that hasn't
been circulating for a million hundreds
of thousands of years and you can
actually make it alive again quote
unquote in the laboratory so this looks
just like a pro virus you have ltrs you
have ltrs in light color the cellular
sequence is on either side and that dark
purple is the duplicated cellular target
so you can tell in the genome if you
sequence any mammalian genome you can
tell where there's a retro element
because you have a duplicated host
sequence and ltrs its signature for
retro element and then we have
retrotransposons which are very similar
but they have extensive mutations so
they don't make particles and these are
often in other species as well yeast
have them Drosophila has them as well 10
to the 2 to 10 to the 4th copies we have
a lot of line elements long interspersed
repeat elements we have 10 to the 4th to
10 to the five of these these are about
twenty percent of our genome they have
no ltrs but they do have this repeated
cellular sequence which suggests that it
occurred by integration and they also
have sequences in the middle and blue
here with homology to RT and gag and
envelope and all of that so these are
probably these have probably been
produced by reverse transcription and
integration as we would suggest here and
there are others too as well there's
signs short interspersed elements 10 to
the 5 to 10 to the 6th of those in our
genomes and then we have these things
called process pseudogenes these are
very interesting they look like they are
cellular genes that were reversed
transcribed and then were integrated
into the genome now because we have all
of these say line elements we actually
have proteins that can be reversed
transcript cases so many cells have
reverse transcriptase very low level
reverse transcriptase activity in them
they don't make particles but that can
copy mRNAs which can then get integrated
and that's how these process pseudogenes
our eyes and this these all of these
endogenous red
for all these retro elements i should
say have been classified according to
what kinds of retroviruses they come
from so they're retroviruses divided
into alpha beta gamma epsilon delta thus
puma the foamy retroviruses and these
are all endogenous retroviruses that are
related to each of those so you can see
there are endogenous lentiviruses in
some species we don't have endogenous
lentiviruses and us but there are
species that do one of them is the Lemur
on Madagascar right the lemurs is only
found in Madagascar and it has
endogenous HIV and how it got it we
don't know because the animal other
animals with related viruses are on the
mainland of Africa of course so these
are there are a lot of these endogenous
viruses and people are very interested
in understanding what they're doing
there could be that right now there is
someone so to become endogenous the
virus has to infect your germ cell right
and it could be that right now there is
someone walking around whose germ line
has been infected with HIV we wouldn't
know it because we're not screening
everyone but that person if he or she
survives could give rise to people who
could populate the earth one day and
they would have endogenous HIV in their
genomes only takes one infection and
then that individual propagates and you
get endogenous transfer now this is all
being exemplified right now on earth the
Koala now the Koala is a very
interesting animal there are a lot of
them in Japanese zoos and most of them
are infected with a koala retrovirus
that is endogenous their germline and
it's thought that this hurts the koalas
so it's not good so it's being studied a
lot the koalas all came from Australia
and they're in the South there are still
colony of koalas without retrovirus in
their genomes so these animals are being
infected in real time or i should say
what happened was a number of years ago
a koala was infected the retrovirus went
into its germline and now that is
propagating throughout the species so
you know most of the koalas in the
japanese ooh came from an individual in
australia
had already been in dodgin eyes so this
is a very interesting story if you're
interested I wrote about it and there
are some references to the literature
this is being studied right now now
we've talked only about endogenous
retroviruses and in fact as I said for a
long time we thought these were the only
viral fossils we had but now in the past
year since we're sequencing so many
genomes and people just look at these
sequences they have been finding
integrated copies of other viral DNA of
other viral genomes not entire genomes
just pieces of them and these include
circovirus the single-stranded DNA
genomes parvovirus is influenza reovirus
you name it rabies virus they are
finding these sequences little pieces of
them not whole virus genomes integrate
it into the germline of many different
species now why is this interesting
because you can date the origin of these
viruses if you take a phylogenetic tree
and search it for the presence of these
integrated copies you can determine when
those viruses went into that species and
from this it's been possible to date
some of the origin of these viruses and
from 10 to 20 to 30 or 40 million years
ago so these are just probably
accidental occurrences for an RNA virus
infects a cell there's a little reverse
transcriptase made in that cell it
copies the viral RNA into DNA and that
accidentally integrates so it probably
has no consequence in the viral life
cycle but it gives us an ability to to
put a time clock on the origin of
viruses now reverse transcriptase has
also been found in Mixel bacteria these
are primitive bacteria that live in the
soil ecoli and archaea they all have
reverse transcriptase activity the same
kind of activity we've talked about
today so it is probable that this enzyme
involved before these these separated
evolutionarily the archaea prokaryotes
and eukaryotes so it's a very old enzyme
most likely and in fact it is believed
to be the bridge between the RNA world
in today's world to remember there was
it's postulated that there was
era where all organisms were composed of
RNA for their genetic material at some
point that was replaced by a DNA world
and of course an RT would be the
candidate enzyme to do the
transformation it could copy RNA into
DNA which eventually could propagate it
on his own so these are really old
enzymes and may explain this very
interesting transition
you